RIGHT ON
BY PHILIPP GRUBAUER.
THEN WITH .
SIGNED WAITING ON HIS STICK.
THEY SCORE! IT DOWN, LOOKS UP A.
WHAT A GOOD PASS BY CAPRICEOFF
AS YOU POINT
BY JOHN LASOUGHT.
YOU SAW IT GO RIGHT BY HIM.
ALONG THE SPURGEON.
GOOD BLOCK BY ADAM LARSSON.
LASS TO THE C BLUE.
THEY SCORE! FLEURY.
YOU SEE ONE DEFENSEMAN
WILKINS.
PART OF THE PROUD HISTORY OF
THIS GREAT SPORTS TOWN.
JOB BY
EVERYBODY, NIGHT NUMBER ONE MOR
GEEKIE.
HE'LL SURVEY FROM TO RYAN HARTMO
BOUNCES ONE IN ONOD POKE-CHECK .
DUHAIME GOES DOWN, McCANN GOT IT
OUT.
SPIN-O-RAMA.N PLAYS IT TO THE
WALL.
FLFLLIZOTTE, LIZOTTE
OUT OF THE CORNER, LOSING
CONTROL, DANCING WITH ITSIDE, S!
NET, BUT MAN, IS THAT OFFENSIVE
ABILITY SHOWING TONOR RASK AND
WITH A SPINNER, KNOCKED OUT IN
FRFRS
TIRED OUT.
FAR SIDE, McCANN JUST WIDE.
ALL THE WAY BACK FORIN.
MOVE IT IT.
CONNOR KOOU
>> J.T.: FASTER.
SOUVENIR. GRUBAUER.
JON LIZOTTE WITH THE
>> John: POWER PLAY ENSUES FOR
MINNESOTA.
SPURGEON OFF THE GOUDREAU.
NHL'S ROOKIE OF THE YEAR TO THE
CORNER, OFF THE
PIPE.
BACK FOR JARED SPURGEON.
HE'LL S S BY MINNESOTA'S MERRIL.
CONNOR DEWAR SAY.
PHILIPP GRUBAUER HAS HAD A BIG
SAY IN TIME!
BRANDON TANEV, WITH AN EMPTY-NET
A LITTLE BIT OF A HOOK THERE.
HE
REMAINING.
BRODIN UP TOP, GUARDED BY
SCHWARTZ RIGHT IN.
HOWTO SAY BILLIARDS.
HE'S ABLE